Fliegen wir?
Naja noch nicht ganz, es fehlt noch ein gewisses Bodentraining.
Geh ruhig mit den Finger auf Kontakt mit der Handschelle.
Jawohl, sehr gut, tadenlos.
Wie du dann sehen wirst schlägt der Feuerstarter Funken.
Das ist ja genial.
Meine Herren, willkommen zur Mission Talking Head.
Unser Ziel ist die Evakuierung von zwei Piloten nach einer Notlandung im Sektor Kilo 7.
Feindliche Kräfte im Einsatzraum, mit Widerstand ist zu rechnen.
Feuerunterstützung durch Saab 105 und PC-7, angefordert von J-Tech.
Zusätzliche Untersützung durch Black Hawks und Kiowas.
Holt unsere Jungs da raus.
Wie so eine Rettung aus der Luft aussieht
sehen wir uns gemeinsam jetzt einmal an.
Robert, zurück am Boden.
Ja, leider.
Well done, gratuliere.
Ich hätte da noch eine Kleinigkeit für dich.
Bei uns ist das sowas wie ein Orden und der gehört da hin.
Danke, ich bleib hier sitzen.
Ich kann mich nicht trennen, danke für die tolle Erfahrung.
Dankeschön.
Profis bei der Arbeit, das war wirklich beeindruckend.
Also auch das SERE-Training, was am Boden alles gelernt werden kann
um im schlimmsten Fall zu überleben.
Aber vor allem natürlich die unterschiedlichen Einsatzmöglichkeiten des Bundesheeres in der Luft.
Das war schon wirklich...
Ja wenn ich ein Resumé ziehen müsste, würde ich sagen wow.
Darf ich den Helm behalten?
Nein?
Ok.
Und das Teil ich meine...
Schaue ich jetzt ein wenig aus wie Tom Cruise?
Nicht?
Schade.